يمكن صنع هذه القمصان وإعادة صنعها وصنعها
مرة أخرى وقد تساعد في
توفير حل لمشكلة متنامية سيتم
التخلص من ثلاثة قمصان من أصل خمسة تم شراؤها اليوم في
غضون 12 شهرًا ، حيث
يتم تسريع الموضة بسرعة في هذه
العملية تقول الأمم المتحدة  تخسر صناعة الأزياء
500 مليار دولار من القيمة كل
عام بسبب الملابس المهملة غير المباعة
ونقص إعادة التدوير على أساس
جزيرة وايت في جنوب إنجلترا ،
عملت إحدى الشركات على تغيير
الأشياء التي يستخدم البريد الإلكتروني فيها التكنولوجيا التي تعمل
على الطاقة المتجددة لتقليل النفايات
و  صُممت قمصانهم ليتم إعادة تصنيعها ،
تم تصميم كل منتج في النهاية
ليتم إرساله مرة أخرى للبدء ، لذا بدلاً من
إنشاء كميات كبيرة من النفايات ، نقوم فقط بإنتاج
منتجات جديدة منها بينما تقدم بعض العلامات التجارية
إصدارات محدودة وخطط إعادة التدوير
عدد قليل جدًا من الشركات لديها  إنشاء
متجر يركز حصريًا على المواد القابلة لإعادة التدوير
خاصة بأسعار معقولة
مطاحن الشاي سر دائري هو هذا
القطن العضوي الذي يستخدم في صنع
قمصان مطحنة الشاي في الواجهة
يتم طباعتها وشحنها في الهند من
جزيرة وايت وكل عنصر يأتي مع
رسوم بريدية مجانية للإرجاع وائتمان متجر مجاني
يشجع إعادة المنتجات المستعملة
ثم إعادة تدويرها في مصنع شقيق في
أوروبا جاهز للطباعة مرة أخرى
تهدف الشركة إلى صنعه  قمصانهم
من 75 في المائة من المواد المعاد تدويرها في
غضون السنوات الخمس المقبلة ، لكن هذا
ليس كل ما يفعلونه لمعالجة النفايات ،
حيث إن 30 ٪ من إنتاج الملابس هو في
الواقع غير مباع ، فنحن في الواقع ننتج
منتجات في الوقت الفعلي ، فنحن في الواقع نصنع فقط
ما يفعله الناس  يحتاجون إليه عندما يحتاجون إليه
، وهنا يأتي دور التكنولوجيا في
التحكم في
أمر إنتاج محسّن للقمصان الفارغة
والتعامل مع طلبات العملاء فور وصولها
إلى أجهزة الكمبيوتر ، حيث تقوم بفرز جميع
الطلبات التي تحتاج إلى الخروج
فورًا ، فأنت تخرج بدقة أولاً
يتم فحص القلم باللون الأزرق ويمكنك
وضعه في f2 وهذا ما
يمكنك من إنشاء كفاءات هائلة إذا
قمت بتطبيق التكنولوجيا بضمير
حي سواء كانت الكتابة  روبوتات بناء الأكواد
تمكنا من إعادة الاستثمار
لتحقيق بعض الأشياء التي أردنا
القيام بها حول الاستدامة
بعد عقد من تطوير
سلسلة التوريد الدائرية والتقنيات التي تركز على الكفاءة ،
تم إنشاء Timo
كمنصة عبر الإنترنت للآخرين لاستخدامها
مجانًا ولديهم حاليًا حوالي 50000
يقول العملاء الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين العلامات التجارية للملابس
والجمعيات الخيرية الدولية مع شركاء من
المشاهير
والمحللين إن تقنيات إعادة التدوير الحالية
غير موثوقة وتعمل
بشكل سيئ ، ولكن من خلال صنع المنتجات
المصممة لإعادة التدوير ، فإن رسائل البريد T تقول
إنهم طوروا حلاً فعالاً لإعادة التدوير ،
لذلك بعد كل العمل الشاق
لماذا تختار  للتخلي عنها ، يتعلق الأمر
بما إذا كنت تريد حقًا
حل المشكلة أم لا ، ونحن نفعل ذلك ، وهذا
يعني المشاركة